Alors...
Qu'est-ce qu'on a aujourd'hui ? Oui ?
Il est arrivé. Qui ça "il" ?
Hé ben, heu... Le... Le monsieur du rendez-vous.
Je comprends pas. Il s'est pas... Il a pas... Il a pas donné son prénom ?
Oui. Oui, oui... C'est... Oui ?
Ha bah, vous-savez-qui.
Mais quoi ? Allez, crache ta valda, vas-y... Hé bah je ne peux pas.
Pour le nez, c'est ça ? Non.
Bah si, parce qu'on a dû vous charrier au collège sur le...
Non. Pas du tout.
Je viens pour autre chose.
Ouais ? Bah ouais, bah je vous écoute...
Comment je m'appelle ?
Ouais, ouais... Ah oui bah oui...
Non, c'est une question ! Comment je m'appelle ?
Ouais, absolument, oui. Vous voyez, vous voulez pas le dire.
Si, je m'apprêtais à le dire. Hé bah oui mais non.
Alors, là je dois avouer que...
Je m'attendais pas à vous voir ici.
Il y a pas de problème avec Harry Potter ?!
Bah d'une certaine manière si.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Quelqu'un lui a jeté un sort encore une fois ? Ça va me soûler ça.
Non, non. Il est tranquille dans la bibliothèque.
Ok ! Donc c'est quoi le problème alors ?
Bah vous voyez bien !
J'ai beau être la magicienne la plus douée de toute ma génération, il y en a toujours que pour Harry Potter.
Vous le dîtes bien. Merci !
Harry-par-ci, Harry-par-là...
Vous savez combien de fois par jour, on dit le mot "Harry Potter" ?
Non je sais pas. C'est plus de 1000.
C'est beaucoup.
Ouais. Et combien de fois on dit "Hermione Granger" ?!
Moins ?
A part quand on faisait l'appel en classe, jamais.
Ok bah je... je...
V...
O...
L... Non !
Là, vous l'épelez !
Bougez pas, je l'écris. Non !
Harry Potter !
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui vous amène ici, Harry Potter ?
Je trouve que j'ai pas fait beaucoup de points, cette saison.
Bah vous êtes quand même le meilleur marqueur de la saison avec 2500 points au total donc...
Oui ! Mais la saison d'avant, j'en ai fait combien ?
8000. Et celle d'avant ? 9000...
Donc moi je demande: "Pourquoi y'en a pas plus cette saison ?!"
Je suis tout à fait au courant mais je peux pas bouger les lignes. C'est un truc comptable à la con...
Vous savez que j'ai fait une potion magique aujourd'hui ?
Bon bah 10 points.
Ce midi, j'ai débarrassé la table...
Ah ça, c'est bien. Ça c'est 25 points.
Ah, j'ai été sympa avec un Poufsouffle.
400 points.
Vous savez pourquoi on a jamais de point ?
Parce que vous êtes nuls ?
Parce que c'est quasiment impossible de dire: "100 points pour Pouf..."
100 points pour Pours...
Bah je l'allais, c'est juste que je me suis arrêté avant !
100 points pour Pour...
100 points poursouffle.
100 points pouf...
Vous voyez ! C'est pour ça qu'on est nul !
Non, vous êtes nuls parce que vous êtes nuls.
Ça marche.
C'est quoi ça ?
Un parapluie rose ?
Non, c'est ma baguette magique.
Oui ?
Alors les autres ils ont droit à des goûts exotiques, des plumes de phoenix...
Et moi, j'ai un parapluie rose ?
Oui... Mais tu es puni, c'est pour ça.
Donc la parapluie ça passe crème.
Oui parce que y'en a toujours pour "Gryffondor, Gryffondor" là...
Mais nous, sous prétexte qu'on est Serpentard, on est forcément des connards !
Oui mais en même temps, vous êtes un connard ?
Oui ?
Bah voilà, bah je mets 10 points pour Gryffondor.
Quoi ! Mais c'est dégueulasse, j'ai rien fait, là !
Vous critiquez mes choix ?
100 points pour Gryffondor.
Excusez-moi ? Oh, Harry Potter !
J'ai oublié de préciser, en fait, tout à l'heure j'ai fait pipi et j'ai baissé la lunette à la fin.
Mais ça, c'est magnifique ça ! 400 points pour Gryffondor !
Vous êtes sérieux là ?
Non vous avez raison... 400 c'est pas assez... 500, 500 Harry !
Voldemort...
Soyez attentif...
Ah oui et notre emblème, il y aurait moyen de le changer ?
Parce que, moi, j'avais pensé à un tigre...
C'est stylé un tigre !
C'est stylé un tigre mais ça ressemble au lion des Gryffondor donc...
Une truite ? Non. Un tourteau ! Non. Une langoustine ? Non.
Aucun animal marin... Une huître ? Non !
Et...
Les points pour Gryffondor ?
Bah quoi encore ?
Bah moi je me pète les rouleaux à faire les meilleures potions, à sauver les miches de tout le monde, à faire des sorts hyper durs...
Je choppe 16 points. Harry, il débarque, il attrape une petite balle dorée c'est 100 points direct...
Vous m'expliquez ?
Ok... Vous savez quoi ?
Je vous mets 3 points pour Gryffondor.
Harry Potter !
Oh, il m'a fait coucou, il m'a dit "Coucou" donc ça, c'est 50 points pour Gryffondor !
Maus putain, je fais ce que je veux !
Un faucon ? Non. Un faucon maltais ? Non, toujours pas.
Un pélican ? Nan ! Un toucan ? Non !
Volfou, Voldingue, Volcrazy...
En fait, moi je vous fais des propals qui sont un peu que ce que...
Un tapir ! Est-ce que ça se voit sur mon visage que je veux que tu dégages ?
Un phasme ! Oui, alors j'étais sûr que vous diriez un phasme... Mais c'est un blaireau, ça restera toujours un blaireau...
Maintenant, tu fous le camp !
Donc on récapitule...
Vol...
de...
Mort... Voilà, Volde...
Oui mais c'est mon... Mais c'est à moi, ça...
On peut remettre ça à plus tard, peut-être ?
J'ai... J'ai besoin...
Juste, entendre...
Une fois, quelqu'un le dire...
D'accord...
Et bien, voilà.
Ça se serait pour prendre rdv avec un bon ORL...
C'est au bout du couloir.
Derien !
Oh Dumbledore mais ça fait tellement plaisir de vous revoir !
Alors déjà moi c'est Gandalf, et vous commencez sérieusement me les briser avec votre école à la con, là.
Alors c'est pas une école à la con, quand même, c'est du taff...
Ta gueule !